in the wake of the 2020 presidential
election I believed that challenging the
results on behalf of President Trump
should be pursued in a just and legal
way I endeavored to represent my client
to the best of my ability I relied on
others including lawyers with many more
years of experience than I to provide me
with true and reliable information
especially since my role involved
speaking to the media and to legislators
in various States what I did not do but
should have done your honor was to make
sure that the facts the other lawyers
alleged to be true were in fact true in
the frenetic pace of attempting to raise
challenges to the election in several
States including Georgia I failed to do
my due diligence I believe in and I
value election Integrity if I knew then
what I know now I would have declined to
represent Donald Trump in these
post-election challenges I look back on
this whole experience with deep remorse
this is a very sad scene not even just
for Jenna